do you have a six-pack no off
Bobby
oh that hurt that wouldn't hurt uh hello
I'm Travis I'm Paige sorry button you're
inclined phones give each other a little
sniff let's explore your other senses oh
let me see if I can find
what is it is that sugar cookie oh yeah
yeah
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
sorry
but a fat person having a perfume called
sugar cookies
I am 24. oh okay I am 31. do you like
younger women tend to yeah what do you
do for work page so for work
um we substitute teacher my little
brother actually is a substitute teacher
as well I understand you guys are strong
on a lot right now she's not feeling
this out no no no no she's not in it no
she's not in it at all no she's like yo
what are these questions bro why are you
asking me about being a substitute who
wants to be a [ __ ] substitute
sometimes your brother is a substitute
I'm trying to [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm trying to
[ __ ] hey hey call that teacher that we
call when the real teacher can't make it
to class call the one that everyone
disrespects hey Paige what Stella hey
whatever [ __ ] hey Hunter get to work
stupid like nobody cares about no God
and they do an important job I'm just
saying nobody want to be talking about
the fact that they are substitute do you
two want to see each other I do sure
hi hi I'm one on one date with like a
different teacher I'm so sorry that's
fine
y'all want to see each other yeah
longer hair is kind of what I'm into
right now that's fine um which is like
longer hair on actually attractive women
as well right now do you spin like a
rotisserie chicken in the shower I
prefer to just kind of sit there like uh
you know like a luau Pig
um I just kind of like Let It wash over
me I do yeah
foreign
nasty Ross why are you saying he's dirty
could you sit there he don't scrub don't
do nothing he don't turn around
so this guy was talking to man she was
saying she was dating this dude
[Music]
oh my God even think about it makes me
so so they in the shower right she's
behind him and she's washing his back or
whatever
and she goes to wash his [ __ ] and she
come out she come out of the booty and
there's like clinker Pop there's no no
no no no no no no there's a landfill of
doo doo
she like she she digs it out
like a handful and she goes what the
[ __ ] he's like what so you know you
don't wash your booty
are you like no that's just gay
here's the kicker
she washed his ass
[Music]
she washed his ass oh my God
bro and that's how I used to go with
wifey material I mean listen oh God
self-esteem by being the gutter but she
a real one
I mean it'll get more lower than that
you gotta clean the Booty like groceries
yo wash your ass guys I think
heteronormative I think hetero being
heterosexual is awesome the wash your
ass
I love being straight [ __ ] that [ __ ]
wash it
yes your ass what's your goddamn ass
listen God damn it please oh hello blind
person yeah hello fellow blind person
like aggressive meat eaters I I didn't
need that to get brought up
um
yeah it's not like a deal breaker you
know like yeah I mean I it's it's how I
kind of act on my values I eat some
spare ribs in front of you are you gonna
be upset no
do you two feel a connection if not
would one of you voluntarily swap with
someone else I feel like I would like to
get to know you more but I don't know if
like it will go any further to be honest
I'm totally understandable but I will
voluntarily step away why would you do
that forever I feel like I can't connect
with him completely because I can't look
at the person that's nice actually so
nice someone like this guy's not for me
so I'm gonna leave so you can have an
opportunity I think it's actually a nice
change from everybody buzzing each other
out the first chance they get it's nice
so shout outs to her I appreciate her
for that
praise music he's in a band do you like
Rockstar not really
lucky for you we are not that successful
so no it's fine can you sing only a
little bit that's not my main thing
um I play guitar bass and drums and I
didn't realize that if I practiced it so
you are with your hands
hey shout out to my sisters I don't know
what it is about musicians but they just
have a whole she went right in for the
fingers she said how strong them then
you twiddle my twiddle done yo she said
come hither I went mm-hmm can you hook
can you finger the fountain can you do a
morse code in my [ __ ] because we need
to send a signal to wear orgasm land
because [ __ ] they coming mm-hmm we
coming
I
the new product by Apple is coming see
if all women had this attitude they
would have gotten the right to vote 100
years priority like honestly this is the
kind of go-getter [ __ ] that just gets
things done her hands are pretty clammy
or demoisturized yes you use a rag when
you shower yes do you use deodorant yes
do you like nice girls or naughty girls
I like nice girls so do you cry not as
much as I should when's the last time
you cried God damn damn the button can't
say [ __ ] now this is not a date this is
an interrogation yeah it's like the
dance Breakers
yeah fair enough being homeless like
being broke I feel like they're basic
get it
I'm sorry uh-oh you rejected you a lot
of things were going well but the thing
about a deal breaker of being broke that
just kind of rubs me the wrong way baby
are you peeking at him he already
rejected me
hey shout outs to disco she said if I'm
gonna take a l i want to see who the
[ __ ] gave it to me
wanna see if I really lost are you
picking him here I hope so and I like
what he rejected said the fact that
being broke is a deal breaker she's like
yeah yeah shout outs to you brother
stand up for the people suffer from
poverty I appreciate you
hello what's your name Patricia Tricia
I'm Erin oh nice to meet you nice to
meet you uh how are you feeling oh I'm
good how are you I'm doing okay I kind
of settled in a little bit at this point
I did Buzz a couple people so oh okay
yeah
I don't think it was red I I would love
to give this a shot okay all right did
you instantly want to reject him because
I'm like he's rejecting I've rejected
like two people
[Music]
damn I feel bad hey make that three
uh because three is a part is a party
over here
get the [ __ ] out of here get the [ __ ]
out of here who are we telling get the
[ __ ] out of here you hoe out of here who
get [ __ ] out of here where [ __ ] out of
here when I [ __ ] out of here okay now
break it down for the hood make it good
like it should you know use a dumb hoe
cause you going home alone hey [ __ ] out
of here get the [ __ ] out of here okay
hey you was buzzing [ __ ]
without no reason Hey listen shout out
to the rock star you said girl you
thought you was going to chain slot
today yo you thought I was feeling you
no uh what's your name
um Vanessa I'm Aaron Hey listen shout
out to the blindfolds but I don't care
how blindfolded I am I'll be seeing them
nipples with that shirt nice to meet you
nice to meet you I hope my reputation
does not precede me really I'm not
trying to be mean I'm just looking for
something that'll work
wow sorry
um
it wasn't red but you know that's that's
all right
oh
why'd you reject me I don't like your
voice
I think Aaron has a lovely voice thank
you I don't appreciate it God damn this
girl
good day
God damn it well I'm not mad at her
because he just gave a bunch of people
else so I mean you know it's coming but
God damn that's a bit much is the other
person here I'm here hey how are you
good yeah I'm doing pretty good what's
your name my name is Vanessa and yours
Vanessa I'm Brian uh have you been up
already
have I been up yeah in here well I don't
get the question have you been in here
and already hit the button on some
people or is this your first time in
here
[Music]
bye
oh this girl's not well
this girl's like so when she does things
is really excuse me no it's not well
yeah he's off it's not well off that was
weird that's off
I think she I think she might have like
issues I'm not even joking yeah it's not
the question that you ask that you want
to keep it light-hearted well I was
getting there so next time ask that
question first no that girl oh my God
that goes off yeah dude that goes off
hey that girl is off hey that goes off
off off
brev I don't know why but I feel like
starting a men's podcast right now okay
am I crazy does not not seem very
entitled and very like aggressive to
tell people how they need to act yeah
yeah right it's off like that's a lot I
like the voice and the guy didn't really
ask anything you didn't say nothing oh
no what do you do I'm a model what about
you I'm an actor I do some modeling too
oh you do yeah fear each other's face
nice okay you're going out your beard uh
no
okay
what kind of modeling do you do yes oh
you're gonna even guessed with a
blindfold like okay uh fashion yeah okay
okay all right I'm there oh I'm wearing
a lingerie lingerie oh yeah shoot okay
okay okay do you have a six-pack no off
by being
mental health so let's see simple some
of this that's really weird
sorry do you think there's the potential
for you to match with someone here
oh no would you voluntarily reject
yourself yes I do
like a cutie full
you're not you're not gonna mess with
anyone
why are you here
why are you here it's really easy with
the people of the butt like you reject
him because he doesn't have us imagine
if I do sat up here and be like yo you
got double D titties nah
but she did
that was crazy that was crazy
mental health this is yeah I honestly
think
hey this might be the most entitled
woman I've seen on these shows yeah yep
how are you okay are we starting oh yeah
oh shoot I'm drawn I'm Skye what do you
do I'm a singer songwriter so I'm
working on my first album right now oh
shoot look at you yeah okay okay I'm in
the entertainment industry too hey we're
two artists let's be broke together
laughs
just letting you guys know two artists
trying to make it work in a relationship
like almost never does
especially if you guys are both aspiring
artists because guess what likely the
odds of any of you making it very slim
to none and then the odds of both of you
making it very slim to them but Apple
what's wrong if one of them makes it
if you're an aspiring artist and your
partner's made it and you did it
friction
there's some resentment that built there
friction yeah that's why it's very hard
for artists to have other friends who
are in the industry doing it super
professionally yeah yeah not the funnest
experience when you're thriving thriving
and killing in all your homies are
struggling to get through one audition
that can build some awkward tension some
resentment some anger just saying now
imagine that in a relationship dynamic
I've seen it many many times what got
you like into that whole world music and
dance has always kind of been my like
Escape yeah yeah so it's like a way to
like express yourself and kind of just
like what are your biggest insecurities
I'm a very go go person and the downside
of that is I'm very impatient so I can
come across as being like dismissive I
think as artists we're all kind of that
way yeah yeah I can relate to that I
like those Vibe
are you from here I'm originally from
Hawaii but I was raised here let's hold
hands okay okay also I'm gonna be in
Hawaii in like a couple weeks
you two should go together which part
everybody goes
that's like where most people go yeah I
never been but
this is one of those things where it's
like there's not that many places you go
yeah
my eyes are watering oh my God
I'm sorry
oh that hurt that wouldn't hurt
that wouldn't hurt bro that [ __ ] hurt my
[ __ ] soul oh my God
oh my God bro that wouldn't [ __ ] hurt
you wanna know why that one hurts so bad
because in my head I was thinking do it
for the content but the way they were
vibing I'm like this can't go wrong she
took a look at him didn't even wait for
it to go red she hit the eject button so
fast that means he knows
[ __ ] I must be ugly to her oh I hate
actors but bro I feel for you man
Hey listen bring it here bro that would
hurt ah oh my God nobody saw that [ __ ]
coming did y'all see that guy oh my God
look at his face look at his face
why did you hit me what were you doing
uh I don't know attraction is a big
thing for me sorry
no that's looks looks
looks that's not attraction because
attraction was was going was was
happening when the blindfolds were on
and then looks was when it happened when
you took them blindfolds off oh God damn
what hey what can you do she wasn't
gonna do she wants to YouTube did that
hurt y'all as much as it hurt me yeah
okay all right listen well let's go
something if you enjoyed today's video
leave a little like in the comment below
but God damn I need to go drink some
water cause that one burned